My moment was the headline of the New York times.
Uh, after,
I guess it was the first or second Republican debate where,
uh,
Trump had gone on CNN and talked about how making Kelly was bleeding through.
And I, and I thought, okay, well, whatever,
but it was the top headline at the top of the New York
times. And I thought that is so strange.
Why is that to humiliate Trump to some degree,
this was just something that you could, you could kind of, you know,
talk about minimally,
but to create an entire narrative over this in order to humiliate them or to get
them canceled was B the beginning for me of like, Oh,
there's something else going on. There's a secret history here.
And you mentioned canceled culture before. And then I brought up the,
the charges of misogyny related to American psycho. Yeah.
So I just read on your Wikipedia and if it's on Wikipedia,
it's gotta be true that you had the deal for American psycho with Simon and
Schuster, but then because what was it women have now,
or the now of women or the something they accused you of being misogynistic.
And then, and then was the book dropped. I mean,
this is sort of an early version of cancel calls. Oh, it is. Yeah,
it was that story up for me. I got it.
Simon Schuster, big deal at Simon and Schuster. I turned the book in,
this is a long time ago in December of 1989.
And throughout 1990,
the book kind of moved through the usual runs of the ladder that it does through
a publishing house, getting copy edited. We figured out a cover. Um, your,
your editor does some basic editing on it,
but there were people in the publishing house who were very offended by American
psycho, uh, usually assistance young people working in, in the,
in the publishing house and weeks started happening,
uh, leaks of some of the most violent passages were being sent to the press and
certain members of the press. And so suddenly it became a story, uh,
and the book hadn't been published yet,
but it became a story and it became more and more controversial.
The more and more that these notorious scenes were leaked. And of course,
out of context, they're horrible. Um, and so anyway, uh,
the controversy got louder and louder and louder, and yes,
kind of like today in a way, uh, Simon and Schuster, uh,
collapsed and said,
we are not going to publish this book because of the outcry in the media. Now,
this is another thing that happened then is that it was actually the corporation
that owned Simon and Schuster that demanded the cancellation.
It was Gulf and Western who owned assignment issues.
And they head of Gulf and Western did not like the controversy did not like the
fact that his,
his corporation was being blemished by this book who ordered the cancellation.
I knew the head of that company of Simon and Schuster quite well. Um, and I,
that he wasn't the one who canceled it, but he was the fall guy.
He had to take it. So anyway, that is what happened, uh, as a happy ending,
because a better publisher picked up American psycho and they published it a few
months later. And, you know, the rest is whatever it is, right.
So it definitely ends happily. And the movies made, never.
Had to say one thing that's very interesting is that Tammy Bruce was the head of
now who was the most against American psycho. She was my nemesis then in 1991.
And now that's hilarious. And now she's on, she's one of the leading lights,
the bright license Fox, actually. And so, uh, I, uh, I don't know,
I find that kind of ironic in the way that the culture war.
I mean,
that fits so much of a lot of the stuff that we've talked about privately
because the wa I've only met Tammy Bruce once it was at, uh, David Horowitz,
freedom center thing, and David Horowitz was a famous left.
Each children of communists who then, you know, became, uh, became, you know,
conservatives and his conference.
He did a thing on sort of the new generation of former lefties that have sort
of woken up. And it was me, Tammy, Bruce, Candace Owens, and,
and a couple other people's that's the only time I met her. And it's funny,
she was opposed to you back then. And here you are,
that's actually a great segue for a little political stuff.
Where are you politically? I mean, I,
I have a sense of kind of where you're at and, and everything.
These days feels sort of a morphous, but.
Um, I was never a political person. I just wasn't,
maybe it was because I was privileged to a degree and politics just didn't
interest me. Why would they, I was a privileged white kid and, uh,
moving from high school into college during the Reagan eighties everything's
seemed whatever. I mean, I kinda, I guess I complained about Reagan mindlessly,
like all of my other kids in my class,
and a lot of people took American psycho to be, uh,
a book that was critical of the values of the Reagan eighties.
And it was critical of some of the cultural values, certainly, uh,
about greed and about yuppie then. But I ended up beef with Ronald Reagan.
I mean, that, wasn't part of what that book was about. Uh, some of his iconic,
uh, iconic iconography is used in the book, but, you know, that was just,
he was as the president during the time that that book took place. Um, and then,
you know,
I was living with someone for a long time who was very invested in politics,
actually ran a couple of gubernatorial campaigns in the nineties,
and I got a close up look to that and I just hated it.
I just hated the whole notion of how it was all played out.
And none of it interested me and it really, and I, I, uh,
during the Obama era, and everything's funny, I mean,
I wasn't really paying attention. Something happened with Trump.
Something happened with Trump that I think has happened to all of us to one
degree or another something was announced. And I, again,
another presidential election cycles coming up and I'm kind of falling in it,
but suddenly I'm following it because it's very interesting to me how the media
is treating the Donald Trump narrative.
Now I'm talking about a media that I had been following closely for 30 years and
trusted someone the New York times, CNN, New York times and CNN,
all of my life,
I read them and I trusted them and I believed in them and it was all they were,
you know, and I began to think that they were missing the story,
that they were going off a different path. That really wasn't the reality,
that wasn't the reality that there was a new narrative that they were forming.
And this began to bother me.
And I don't know why I hear ya.
I don't know why I am I'm non-partisan I never saw myself as a,
I never saw myself really. If I saw, I think we have the similar trajectory.
I think that I was a liberal guy who was gay and was,
you know, rightly so rightly so. It was fine. Uh, not never stridently,
never far left or whatever, but I, you know,
I believe in the good fight on the liberal side, something happened.
I began to see that the sign was curdling. Yeah.
Do you remember, do you remember a moment? Cause a lot of ideas,
a lot of people have like the moment. Yeah. What was mine?
The moment was the headline of the New York times, uh,
after,
I guess it was the first or second Republican debate where,
uh,
Trump had gone on CNN and talked about how making Kelly was bleeding through.
Her eyes. And I, and.
I thought, okay, well, whatever,
but it was the top headline at the top of the New York
times. And I thought that is so strange.
Why is that to humiliate Trump to some degree,
this was just something that you could, you could kind of, you know,
talk about minimally,
but to create an entire narrative over this in order to humiliate him or to get
them canceled was B the beginning for me of like, Oh,
there's something else going on. There's a secret history here.
And that is how I began to become somewhat,
uh, radicalized in a way from who I thought I was to where I
ended up being. And, uh, again, I have to say, I'm not a partisan.
Uh, I, I still am someone who, uh,
is low the vote I'm in the majority of this country. Uh,
and yet what I mean.
Notice, you mean you didn't go to my dumping,
my dumpy polling station over here where I'm pretty sure I can track the area
you weren't there yesterday.
No, I was not there and I'm not going.
To be there. Um, but, um.
Um, I, uh, so, but I, what I found so interesting and really what white,
a lot of it is about is about how I saw the left begin to disintegrate and
a part of the arm. And I thought I was on, I was, I thought it was in that part,
that side of the theater. And I realized that I'm not,
and I don't want to be on this side of the theater if it is this hysterical,
this crazed and it's. And also,
I really hated the creation of narratives that were obviously not
true that were being used to undermine a legally elected president.
Whether I liked him or didn't like him,
I just thought there was something so distinctly un-American about the way the
left was, uh, creating their stories,
that it just began to, um, uh, unearthed.
Yeah. You know, what's super interesting about that, that David Horowitz,
who we just mentioned when I had him in here, um, he's a huge Trump supporter.
And I asked him, do you have a moment when that happened?
And he mentioned the Megan Kelly, uh, bleeding line.
Cause he said for him as someone that had was a conservative, but was,
but didn't understand the Trump thing.
He's like that moment got it for him because,
because it was basically Trump being like, screw all of you,
I played by none of your rules.
So that same moment that sort of had you wake up from a media perspective as a
lefty for him as a conservative was like, that was why he loved Trump.
Weird because yes, the Trump screw all the rules guy is what everyone loves.
That's what everybody loves. Yeah.
And it's so interesting that yet on the other side is what a lot of people are
horrified by.
Who wouldn't normally learn. Right. They're supposed to be.
And yet, because it's Trump and this is the problem with Trump.
And I talk about this again in the book, it is about,
I really believe it's about an aesthetic it's about this guy
and what he looks like.
And I always have said that if Trump was in the package of a Mitt Romney,
it might be more palatable for a lot of people.
And we certainly would not have this kind of like, uh, re what is truly,
I believe Trump story.
Syndrome.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlists, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.